[Music]
bring a bucket and a m for this wet ass
PE give me everything you've got for
this wet ass Beat It Up N word catch a
charge extra large extra hard put this
PW word right in your face swipe your
nose like a credit card hop on top I
want to ride I do a c while it's inside
spit in my mouth look in my eyes this p
word is wet come take a
dive I don't know exactly what to say
about that other than there's a reason
that we are starting with that slightly
edited clip of Ben Shapiro singing wack
which I'm not going to tell you what it
is WAP you can Google it if you want to
find out but there is a reason we are
showing you that at the beginning of the
Ruben report I'm Dave ruin it's November
20th 2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals postgame show as
always Ruben report. locals.com and if
you want to join us later today at 1:00
Eastern for people of the internet with
your calls uh you can go ahead and do
that on your computer machine as well so
you're going okay what Dave why would
you start with that thing it's Monday
it's right before Thanksgiving families
are together right now watching the
program what are you doing what are you
doing well cardi B who is the uh the
singer do you call she's a rapper I
guess not a singer there's a fundamental
difference I suppose between a rapper
and a singer she's a uh she's a rapper
who sang that WAP song uh she's also had
it with Joe Biden and she is now a part
of what I would say is a growing list of
celebrities that have kind of got over
old Joe and you might think well all
right that doesn't really matter we
shouldn't really care about what these
people think and I think there's some
legitimacy to that obviously except that
politics is down Downstream from culture
so when people start waking up it starts
doing other things in culture that maybe
then can bubble up to politics so that
is good so we're going to start with
that but of course the big thing over
the weekend is that Javier Malay is the
new primate prime minister or president
president he is the new president of
Argentina he is a libert Arian some say
an ancap uh and he's sort of the Trump
of Argentina and this story feels like
it's going to proliferate around the
globe because he's kind of wacky he's
out there he hates the wers it's
basically he ran on this like crazy
anti-government anti- spending hate the
wers despise
socialism uh platform uh and he won big
time and maybe it's a bit of a signal
that things can start Chang in in the
west so that's what we're going to be
doing today and I just realized that
Clyde is in studio can we uh can we take
a picture of Clyde posted in locals for
the people Clyde is hanging out in
studio today before we get to it guys
let me tell you about gravity to fire
shoes I want to tell you about something
that's been making my days a whole lot
easier gravity to Fire Shoes these shoes
are something else I mean I'm a fan of
comfortable Footwear everyone knows that
but these show shoes take it to a whole
new level more than just shoes they're
basically clouds for your feet I'm not
choking in a double blind study by Olive
View UCLA Medical Center and published
in the Journal of the American podiatric
Medical Association participants
experienced 85% less knee pain it's the
most powerful shock absorption system
put into a shoe gravity to fire has this
patented versoshock technology it's like
a mini trampoline in your shoes whether
you're strolling through the park
running errands R just lounging at home
these shoes have got your back or I
should say your feet even better they're
stylish you get both comfort and style
that looks good and feels great so
here's the deal this gravity to fire
offer is exclusive to Ruben report
listeners head over to
gy.com gd.com use the promo code ruben2
to check out get an extra 20 bucks off
your first order the $20 discount as a
thank you gift from Gravity to fire for
you being here with us today why not
treat your feet to some well-deserved
Comfort check out gy.com gdf y.com
ruben2 is the code and now back to me
okay okay so Ben Shapiro singing WAP an
odd way to start your Monday but the
reason we did it was because cardi B now
I'm more of a Tina Turner guy myself but
cardi B apparently is popular with the
young people uh she did a little video
she's had it with Joe Biden and the
Democrats and she's kind of making some
sense I need try to spread this video
and if something happens to me is
because I'm speaking truth and here's
the truth right in New York there is 120
million budget cut there's a 120 million
budget cut in New York that is going to
affect Schools public libraries and um
the police department yall know I don't
give about the cops but like it is what
it is there's going to be an 120 million
doll budget
cut with
schools with libraries and the cops and
the police department and a $5 million
budget cut in Sanitation of a budget cut
in sanitation we going to be
drowning rats I'm not this year don't
ask me I don't give a the resume that
they send I don't give I'm not endorsing
no presidents no more cuz how is that
aund hundred million budget cut in New
York City for for
um schools Library uh police safety and
sanitation yeah Joe Biden is talking
about like yeah we could fund two Wars
we could fund two Wars talking about we
don't got it but we got it like we're
the greatest nation no the we're not
we're going through some right now like
say it say it we really going through we
we we really really really really really
really really really are right now I'm
lucky I'm lucky I'm blessed I'm whatever
the but like what what's going to happen
to my nieces what's going to happen to
my my nephews what's going to happen to
my cousins my aunts my friends say the
word but we're going through a recession
right now we really really really are
major Eric said it there is a budget cut
going on the in in in New York and
little by little it's going to go in y
State all right first off again Connor
last week he almost broke his finger the
bleep finger uh I think pretty much we
took it out today you're going to need a
couple days off for Thanksgiving to get
that finger in order that's number one
number two what kind of hat is that that
she's wearing there what is that hat I
I'd like to wear a hat like that what
what do you call that it's that was just
a shower cap is that just a shower cap
I'd like to get one of those uh but to
the substance of what she was talking
about and I think she's a little
confused about some things in that Joe
Biden is not really in charge as the
President of the United States with the
New York City Sanitation budget and
things of that nature her overriding
point that they have these types of
people right leftists and Democrats and
celebrities and Hollywood and musicians
they've all supported the Democrats and
they are suddenly starting to realize
that the Democrats whether they're the
president of the United States or
they're the mayor of New York City Eric
Adams or the governor of New New York
State Kathy hokel that they ruin
everything right they need budget cuts
because they created Sanctuary States
and Sanctuary cities and they let all
these people come and they give them all
these services and they are literally
kicking homeless people out of homeless
shelters to put illegal immigrants into
and all of these things so whether she's
a little muddled in sort of technically
how some of this works um maybe the
shower cap was on too tight uh she's
making actually a good point and
basically I'm not going to endorse
anybody now I don't know how many people
out there we'd have to run the numbers
on this are sitting at home going I
don't know am I going to vote for Biden
or Trump or democrat Republican like
what's cardi B doing I'll figure you
know I'm gon to go with cardi B but the
point is the culture does matter right
everything that has led to this odd
place that we are at where that suddenly
you know chopping genitals off and
beheading people uh is somehow good to a
certain set of people it's because we
have culture Surly failed young people
but maybe that's turning around a little
bit so now I want to show you a video of
comedian Kevin Hart he was on a podcast
a couple days ago and he too has had it
with Joe Biden and I would remind you
before we play it we showed you a clip
last week of The Rock The Rock on Joe
Rogan's show saying that he's over Joe
Biden as is everybody else so something
is happening here Kevin Hart I was
watching Biden there's a clip of Biden
what Biden says and this is I I've
probably watched this clip I'm not into
politics at all but this I Biden goes I
got something important I want to say
and the whole world needs to hear it I
need everybody to listen right now and
he takes a beat he
goes I forget
it president of the United States so
people are realizing it right for years
literally before Joe Biden was President
I and I'm not the only one was talking
about there's something cognitively not
right with this guy we all know it the
wandering the confusion the starting of
sentences that either don't end where
they're supposed to go or just Meander
off completely like him wandering
through the the White House lawn etc etc
um between cardi B realizing that
there's a sanitation problem and blaming
that on Biden and then say Kevin Haro
and this guy's not mentally right it
does show that something is happening
and then what did we have what was it
about two weeks ago when David Axelrod
former Obama guy suddenly was tweeting
out oh Joe's getting kind of old like
they really are figuring it out right
now Gavin Nome hosting XI jingping the
president of China like something is in
The Ether but I mention all of this
because one of the things that the
machine does really well is no matter
how bad the Democrats are no matter how
decrepit they are or confused or
whatever is going on in their brains no
matter how bad their policies are that
lead to sanitation problems in New York
City City and everything else the
Democrats always sort of stay in power
at least culturally right occasionally
we get some Republican presidents or
republican Governors or whatever but the
cultural apparatus always somehow leans
left and one of the way they've been
ways they've been doing this for years
now is basically saying to anyone who
thinks a little bit differently you are
racist you are
Hitler here's Jimmy Kimmel talking about
Trump and
yes n a lot of people have been
comparing Trump to Hitler lately but
there are there's some major differences
between for instance Hitler was married
to a woman who loved him
okay and and I will
say I get why people believe Trump is
intentionally using words the Nazi used
I I just don't agree that he is in order
to know what words the Nazis used you
you'd have to read okay you'd have to
have some basic knowledge of History
Trump thinks Frederick Douglas is alive
and doing an amazing job he thinks
Lincoln invented the Town Car okay so he
isn't echoing Nazi terminology he's
coming up with it all on his own and you
have to give credit where creditors do
you know that they actually electrocute
those people so that they know when to
laugh like they're all just sitting
there like and then that's when you're
supposed to laugh that's when you're
supposed to laugh it's just so terrible
again people are tuning these things out
in droves but we cannot understate the
damage they have done when still even
right now as we have people hordes of
people all over the globe calling for
genocide that the person that they n the
number one person that they called
Hitler over the last couple years was
Donald Trump who actually led to peace
deals in the Middle East and everything
else but I want to connect this to to
another thing because one of the things
that's really interesting since October
7th uh is that BLM black black lives
matter the organization black lives
matter which for two years wrecked Chaos
on our streets right and demolished
buildings in the name of diversity and
peace and burn down Pep Boys and they
rans sack Target and you could take
anything you want out of Best Buy and
all of those things BLM which all of its
leaders got super rich and had giant
corporate power they never sent a black
kid to college never helped a black
person own a small business or anything
else one of the thing that's things
that's interesting over the last couple
weeks is how just overnight it just
flipped into a pramas organization and
the apparatus the community organizing
let's not forget Barack Obama was a
community organizer before he was
Senator and before he was president the
way that they have gotten these young
people to just show up in drobes put on
the kefia uh hold these flags chant
things that they have no idea what they
mean uh it's it's because of the
cultural rot that has occurred in this
country so now there's this guy Logan
Paul you've seen Logan Paul over the
years and he's a what he's a fighter now
and what was he originally he was like
some YouTube guy again you don't have to
care about him the same way you may not
care about cardi bat but you have to
understand that these people infect the
minds of young people uh here's Logan
Paul it's a video from a couple days ago
and then a throwback of Logan Paul uh no
reverse that it's a video from a couple
years ago and then uh a current video of
Logan Paul explaining that his BLM woke
thing all of it it's the best work he's
ever
done it is not enough to be not racist
you have to be anti-racist yes and it's
still pinned on your Twitter it I think
it's the most important thing I've ever
said in my life it like out of
everything I've ever done and I I said
this after that podcast out of
everything I've ever done in my life
that clip might have the biggest impact
out of everything I've ever done more
than the boxing yeah wow I think so I
think so I am not familiar with all the
incredible work of Logan Paul as you can
tell uh but a lot of people are whether
it's his YouTube videos or boxing or
whatever else and he is screaming that
the most important thing you can be is
anti-racist now I suspect he's not
giving all of his money to black people
which would help his anti-racist cause
but uh you know how this thing works but
again you don't have to care about him
you don't have to care about cardi b or
any of these things but you have to
understand you don't have to care about
Jimmy Kimmel but you have to understand
it starts affecting the brains of the
people who are consuming this and who
are
algorithmically let's say push into
believing this nonsense so now speaking
of nonsense there's a segue on the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC over the weekend uh a Woman by the
name of Mara gay and we've discussed
Mara gay a couple times on this program
she's no fan of mine we'll get to that
in just a second uh she went on NBC
MSNBC and tried to tell people with a
straight face that her six-year-old
goddaughter now has less rights than she
had and it has something to do with
Trump and fascism go nobody's going to
go to the polls for democracy nobody
really cares if women don't have the
right uh to decide what happens to their
own bodies well it turns out that
Americans aren't as cynical as the rest
of us at least a majority of them and
that is why they're voting because they
do see Donald Trump I believe for who he
is they do see fascism they are
concerned about it they want to have a
better future for their children my
goddaughter is six years old and has
fewer rights than I had 30 years ago
what the flying f are you talking about
lady what right does your six-year-old
goddaughter not have it simply not true
also this trick that they do it's a
psychological trick for people that are
watching MSNBC who aren't that bright in
the first place but you have to vote our
way because every time you don't vote
our way our way means
democracy and if you don't vote our way
you get fascism right although these are
the same people who have all of the
corporate and government power which
when you combine those things that
actually is the F-word anyway maray we
saw the video and then I was like you
know what maray has been unkind to me
and this program she's besched all of us
in this room before uh this is her in
the New York Times you may remember this
When She interviewed Andrew Yang when he
was running for mayor listen to her
question to Andrew Yang over the years
you've built your brand by frequently
doing radio and other appearances with
all with right-wing media personalities
at times you said the Democrat Party
should gravitate away from Identity
politics you've supported automating
fast food workers at times why appear on
shows like the Dave Ruben show who
regularly hosts white
supremacists I don't know what that has
to do with automating fast food joints
but okay yes so first off it's not it's
it's called the Ruben report Lady it's
not the Dave Ruben show I may do a
spin-off one day we'll call it the da of
Ruben show I don't know I literally
don't know any wh supremacists I've ever
put on the show but anyway you get it
this is just what they do with
everything but let's do a little bit
more because as you know Thursday is
Thanksgiving it is the one day a year
that Americans get around the table and
get a chance to hopefully be thankful
for every bit of goodness that this
country has given us and the freedoms
that we have and all of that stuff plus
eat some turkey and stuffing and you
undo the pants in the middle of the meal
and all that well you know what happens
before Thanksgiving according to our
mainstream media we have to put people
on television who will tell you that
Thanksgiving is terrible this country is
evil founded on racism etc etc here's a
Native American activist on CNN calling
to end Thanksgiving every year we go
through uh these rituals these are
rituals these holidays these Concepts
these they're part of our Collective
cultural mythology and in America there
is a settler a European Foreigner alien
settler cultural mythology from my eyes
as an indigenous person we've been here
for a lot longer than the settler
institutions are are telling us or are
teaching our children and we're just now
in a state where we're consciously
deconstructing um Euro hetero
Christian
programming European foreign settler
colonists and it needs to be
deconstructed do you see how for the
last month when I've repeatedly been
saying if you think when they're done
with the Jews that they're just going to
wrap it up this is just the beginning
and it's being seeded into our
mainstream media narrative now once that
guy gets on there and says that we
Americans and by the way the the guy
that he's talking to the black host of
the show he's talking to you dude you
have no right to be here either what
he's saying is Well you guys are
European foreign settler colonists and
we're going to have to decolonize you
and by the way we're cool with beheading
when it comes to decolonizing we're cool
with raping and killing babies and a
whole bunch of other stuff so get ready
for it and there will be people out on
the streets I guarantee you young people
calling for violence against Americans
trying to blow up embassies all of the
stuff that you can possibly imagine and
some stuff you probably can't imagine
but the fact that the week or just the
days leading up to Thanksgiving this is
the n since they are putting on CNN you
just have to again when I talk about why
did they call Trump Hitler for years and
then you see where we're at now I'm just
trying to show you they're doing it
right now they're calling America a
colonist Nation white settlers
Christians white people ah it's all
scary just wonder where they're going to
be at in a couple years uh and if you
wonder where they're going to be at in a
couple years you must just only go to
colleges of today because they are
breeding grounds for this leftist lunacy
that then leaks out into society here is
a a woke professor at the University of
Denver uh she teaches a class called
critical whiteness in my day that would
have been racist but what are you going
to do uh anyway University of Denver and
here she is uh teaching that white
people are inherently guilty of the
worst thing
racism and he talks about um at best as
a white male you can be what was it
anti- anti-racist white racist meaning I
personally I'm disgusted and will fight
personally against this but at the same
time I benefit as a white person in a
white SP Society something I don't want
but I still be I still bequeath
benefit I don't know I I trying to think
of of an equivalent because I know
that's hard that's kind of hard just to
soak in right so I think I'm
like okay do I have any Catholics in the
room can I just go here you know you're
all sinners
it doesn't matter if you you know had
premarital sex or you had a child out of
wedlock you're all Sinners anyway you
know you know what I'm saying because by
virtue of that that overarching
ideology woman should be in a sanitarium
not teaching young people that they are
guilty of something that they are not
guilty of she knows nothing of every
single person's history in there and all
of the stuff but do you see what they do
so on one hand CNN brings on Native
Americans to talk about decolonization
and white Christians and all that then
University of Denver has classes to
inherently te or to teach white people
that they are inherently guilty that
this experiment this great experiment
this precious beautiful experiment of
the United States is the bad thing and
we wonder why everything is collapsing
and young people are out there chanting
for genocide and everything else I think
you got it but now let's continue
because it's not just the crazy
craziness of CNN or Jimmy Kimmel it's
not just the craziness of our College
institutions it's also the Looney Birds
over at the view and they had uh the
Department of Education Secretary Miguel
Cardona on and well you're not going to
believe it he also thinks that America's
racist the Supreme Court is evil and the
rest of it and here he is with the noted
racist herself sunny
hustin but let me ask you this in terms
of inclusivity this past summer the
Supreme Court overturned nearly 50 years
of affirmative action and college
admissions and you called recently that
a new low point and warned quote in
danger we are in danger of a new Jim
Crow era in some parts of this country
are we already seeing the effects of
that decision and and in your view how
long will the impact last look we cannot
rest until the diversity on our campuses
reflects the beautiful diversity of our
country that's what makes this country
special yeah
and unfortunately we're not there and
the Supreme Court decision in my opinion
took us a step backward but what I am
seeing are college presidents doubling
down they're recruiting better they're
engaging with K12 institutions we have
an opportunity to really go better than
what the affirmative action results are
uh we need to hold it ourselves
accountable and we need to remind
colleges that we want our children to go
to schools where they're going to learn
with people that are different than
them these are these are such bad people
and the fact that the view audience this
is upper west side New York City these
are all white liberals oh my God it's so
great affirmative action you idiots do
you realize it's your children that will
not get into schools your children who
you put all the money to put them in
private schools and you did everything
right with family and all that other
stuff well sorry they're white so
they're just not going to get into
schools anymore the reversal of course
and they're talking about the Supreme
Court reversal of affirmative action
related to college admissions which
happened a few months ago of course was
right we are supposed to be a colorblind
Society why is it forget the Jews right
it used to be Harvard and the IB League
schools were always discriminating
against the Jews because Jews cared
about education and family and hard work
so there were too many Jews at Cornell
too many Jews at Harvard this is a fact
so they used to discriminate against
Jews but it has moved on from the
colleges are obviously done with the
Jews now they openly discriminate
against Asian kids because Asian kids
and it doesn't matter whether they're
Japanese Chinese Korean whatever
generally speaking their culture leads
them to working hard tiger mom right you
might say that's a little bit overboard
and maybe they should be playing sports
more instead of studying eight hours a
day but the the overall feeling of the
culture is one of hard work and
dedication and meritocracy and all those
things and what he wants and what racist
Sunny hustin want is people to get in
based on the color of their skin and of
course what that does over time is
degrades the entire system so if you
have a young kid who gets into let's say
a a high school like a private high
school not because he deserves to be
there because of the work that he's put
in and everything else but because of
his skin color now he gets into a
college because of his skin color now he
gets into grad school because of his
skin color then he gets the job because
of skin color etc etc eventually our
doctors will not know how to perform
heart surgery our Pilots will not know
how to fly and you will be an idiot if
you don't want a white doctor you will
want a white doctor because the doctors
that are white will have to work the
hardest and been the most qualified to
get the freaking job in the first place
I'm getting cancelled for that one Dave
ruin only wants white
doctors any who uh let's continue with
the view because Anna Navaro who of
course lives in Florida enjoys all the
freedoms of Florida then flies up to New
York to complain about Florida all the
time uh here she is completely lying
about the Florida education system which
is really probably the best in the
entire country we've removed wokeism we
have removed all of the racial stuff our
school are doing incredibly well and we
have no state income tax we've still
been able to fund our schools despite no
state income tax and here she is what
just everything this woman says is a lie
enjoy I think Joe Biden recruited very
damn well when it comes to the Secretary
of Education you make me so incredibly
proud and the way you represent this
fills my heart every time you're here
and every time I see you but we could
spend an entire show on what's happening
on my home state of Florida Florida
schools are a mess they're teaching kids
that some black people personally
benefited from slavery and there's so
many books that have been banned that
pop singer Pink is actually giving them
out in her Florida concerts so the
culture wars being waged in our
classrooms you've said very bluntly
there is a team that is fighting for
kids and a team that is fighting against
kids what do you mean by that look look
at what we're trying to do we're trying
to open doors for all kids you talked
earlier about like um like the GI Bill
Public service loan forgiveness is that
for public servants to get them into
professions nurses like we're trying and
then we have a team that's trying to cut
funding we have a team that's trying to
give local control that's what we as a
teacher I didn't want the federal
government telling me what to teach or
the state government right yet we have
state governments taking control of what
teachers and parents could decide for
their kids we need to wake up and see
what's happening not only in Florida but
in other states you know what I just had
a thought Conor can we start when we
play clips from The View can we put them
upside down cuz I think there's a
Bizarro World mentality with that show
where everything they say that they
purport to be good is actually the
reverse so she's lying about the schools
you all know about the book band so I
guess pink again I'm not a pink uh what
what would be a white singer that I like
I like Stevie Nicks let's say uh so pink
I guess is now handing out the books at
her concerts that they've banned in
Florida so I guess if you go to a pink
concert and you bring your kid they're
going to learn how you can I don't even
want to say it like these books are
pornography for children those are the
books that have been banned so okay you
guys all get that like you want to go to
a pink concert and then your
six-year-old son can have a gender queer
book so
ridiculous uh they are the ones who want
the massive control over the Board of Ed
right who who's in it with the teachers
unions who's in it with the Board of Ed
the Department of Education it's the
Democrats des santis and Florida we have
fought against that so that parents can
go to school board meetings and say oh
you know we would just prefer not to
have pornography in the third grade uh
narrative could we possibly do that
would would that just be okay so of
course every everything they say is a
lie but now I want to show you another
way it's not just of course that they
can lie about it on television you guys
get that whether it's whether it's the
Jimmy kimlay or whether it's the buay or
all that stuff there's something
actually much more nefarious happening
directly to your kids and they're
constantly going after the children so
this is wild this is from the libs of
Tik Tock Twitter account uh and you know
Libs of Tik Tok she gets in a lot of
trouble with all the all the evil people
Froot Loops promotes free access to a
digital library on their serial boxes
for kids the library offers a range of
books to teach kids themes of equity
diversity and inclusion Kelloggs wants
to indoctrinate your children with
breakfast cereal stop giving them your
money instead shop at official Public
Square where you can find Millions of
products from companies that you can be
sure to share your values check them out
here blah blah blah but look at these
images on the Froot Loops box um you can
see their digital library and what's
going on in their Digital Library it's a
free online library of equity diversity
and inclusion family Centric content
including books podcasts and more Crea
in Partnership blah blah
blah all of this all of this it is first
off you if you are giving I have two
young children like they have had
basically no sugar they're eating
organic they're eating real foods these
kids are huge great happy and healthy
and I will never the idea of giving them
just a bowl of pure sugar you're just
giving them a bowl of sugar and dye when
you put Froot Loops and I get it I love
Froot Loops when I was a kid right but
like there's a better way to parent but
they are trying to hack their brains in
two ways they want to hack their brains
get them get them hopped up on sugar
nothing nutrition in the first place and
then oh you're all hopped up on sugar
now go to our website where you can
learn that you're racist and then you
got this little 5-year-old who's hopped
up on sugar go I'm
racist it's just
insane um all right you might go David
you called me David there it's you're
feeling very serious about this David
it's a little bit much what you're
pushing on us what are you saying
they're trying to Sugar up your kids
brains so that they'll start hating
themselves for being white what would
what what where would that lead where
would that lead where would it lead well
it would lead to a place like here we're
going to show you a compilation video
this is Canada and London Canada and
London uh these are young people who
have lost their minds I assume this is
sugar and or Froot Loop
induced Lord the
resistance the resistance there is only
one solution there is only one solution
for the
revolution
retion
[Music]
livey father it's not you it's your
ancestors it's to the reason why you're
figh me today is because of what my
people did the reason why you here today
is because of what your people did to my
people you do do anything this country
you're a disgrace you're a
disgrace the reason why you're in the
street
these you see what we did there like you
hop these people up on sugar you hand
them diversity documents and then you
have this what was that a 10 12 year old
kid screaming about in
in Canada was the first one and then the
other guy was London but again all of
these things it's just a series of
things to break the brains of everyone I
saw this one this morning on CNN here
this one this is just look at this
freaking thing this Rabbi says the
fundamental threat in Israel is not
Hamas and we are to believe that this
Rabbi Jessica Rosenberg okay Jessica
with her goatee that is a dude dressed
as a woman pretending to be a rabbi as
Carol Martz my friend who's been on the
show many times from the New York Post
pointed out there's something
interesting happening here like they
have to go to these crazy crazy people
to make it seem like those are those are
the Jews right like here's this dude
with a goatee pretending to be a rabbi
and he's into Hamas because you know
because you know he would be treated
really well if he went to Gaza that the
point is that that sane people have
unified we're more quiet our protests
aren't as violent we're not always
screaming to kill everybody and
everything
else you get the point you get the point
these people are insane and we must keep
calling out their Insanity so what do
you do what do you do well you have to
call out the insanity and then you have
to defend the people who are unjustly
being called bigots racists Nazis
anti-semitic etc etc so something really
interesting happened over the last
couple days uh there was a tweet from an
account this is just a completely as far
as I know a totally random Twitter
account but it ended up getting Elon
Musk into a bunch of hot water so I want
to show you this uh this guy this guy
it's just breaking bat whatever that is
wrote Jewish communities have been
pushing the exact kind of dialectical
hatred against whites that they claim to
want people to stop using against them
I'm deeply disinterested in giving the
tiniest now about Western Jewish
populations coming to the disturbing
realization that those hordes of
minorities that support flooding their
country don't exactly like them too much
you want the truth said to your face
there it is now I will unpack that tweet
in just a moment what what the reason
that that Twitter uh that that tweet
specifically went viral is because Elon
Musk responded to that and said you have
said the actual truth okay so you might
hear that original statement Jewish
communities and feel like there's
something anti-semitic going on here now
it gets cleaned up just a bit because
now suddenly everybody started calling
Elon Musk an semites so then Elon Musk
followed up and he said the ADL unjustly
attacks the majority of the West despite
the majority of the West supporting the
Jewish people and Israel this is because
they cannot by their own tenants
criticize the minority groups who are
their primary threat it is not right and
it needs to stop so that is 100% right
that is absolutely clear uh a random
person on Twitter cleaned it up a bit
more for Elon he wrote yes but it is not
fair to say or truthful to say that
Jewish communities promote dialectical
hatred towards whites say what you want
about the ADL but don't generalize about
the Jewish community and Elon responded
to that you're right that this does not
extend to all Jewish communities but it
also not just limited to the ADL okay so
you get the point here what someone what
this original person was saying is there
are these groups like The ADL now he
said Jewish community so that's a little
bit butchered and I'm going to get to a
video of Ben Shapiro cleaning this up a
bit more in just a second but the
overriding point that there are groups
like The ADL who spend way too much time
calling everyone on the right Hitler
racist and bigoted and Trump's evil and
all of those things rather than deal
with the people who are here now who are
chanting for genocide and everything
else and and in many cases who have led
to a lot of the bad immigration policies
and tried to take out anyone who has
wanted a border or anything else that
was elon's point he followed up one more
time on this he said and at the risk of
being repetitive I am deeply offended by
the adl's messaging and any other groups
who push de facto anti-white racism or
anti-asian racism or racism of any kind
I'm sick of it stop now okay these are
all by the way themes that I talk about
on this show all the time right so
obviously I've been a big defender of
the Jewish people and of Israel but I am
constantly defending white people and
Christian people and straight people and
Asian people because these things are
all deeply connected to how evil
collectivism and wokeness is so over the
last two days there has been a massive
assault by Media Matters and the ADL and
a bunch of these other companies to
boycott Twitter right hit Elon Musk
where it hurts go after his advertisers
well Ben Shapiro got word of this and he
fully defended Elon Musk and it's
certainly true there are a lot of
liberal Jewish organizations that
supported a lot of the same policies
that have now imported a lot of people
who really hate Jews and westerners into
the west and a lot of the very same
people who are pushing Dei
intersectional politics are now
realizing the wages of
that that's true a huge number of people
in the media decided now was the time to
link musk in the alt-right and the
so-called Jewish question and support
the notion that musk is some sort of
crypto naazi now it's not a coincidence
again that a lot of the people doing
just that are happily calling for Israel
to ceasefire in its war with Kamas see
very often anti-Semitism becomes a
political football when you can hang the
label on Donald Trump or Elon Musk and
you're on the left you do it however
when you're forced to denounce proas
protesters shouting from The River To
The Sea Palestine must be free suddenly
you get a little shy thus the same media
leaping on both Trump and musk has been
downplaying the open Jew hatred at
massive proas protests around the globe
instead propagating lies about Israel's
supposed human rights violations instead
they're focusing in on their political
enemies like Trump and musk and deeming
them the acolytes of Hitler meanwhile
the actual Hitler acolytes who are out
there waving mind comp they're like
those people I mean they are a Preston
Brown all right so you get it if you lay
it out cleaner than Ben there is no
reason to think that Elon Musk is an
anti-semite even if you want to get hung
up on Jewish communities right as
opposed to Jew you know these Lefty
Jewish related organizations like
everyone sees exactly what's going on
here but then what happened well the
left-wing hacks at Media Matters started
a coup against Elon and Twitter and they
started this massive boycott and they
got a whole bunch of companies like
apple and bunch more to now boycott
advertising on Twitter uh here's a tweet
from Travis and Flint with a bit more
happening now this morning Elon Musk
announced a lawsuit against Media
Matters and those who colluded with them
in attempt to smear x what happened
Media Matters ran an ALT account and was
refreshing the feed at feed at an
alarming rate in an attempt to get ads
to appear next to bad content the
reality is the content was only seen by
one or two people including the media
matters account that published it X
actually did what they said they do they
limited the reach of anything offensive
what Media Matters wants is for the
internet to be completely regulated so
the only content they agree with so only
content they agree with can be shared
they're using advertisers and
manipulating data to achieve that who's
excited to see Media Matters be sued
into Oblivion and yes uh Elon Musk is
going to sue the Twitter so we will find
out more about that I think he's he's
lodging the official lawsuit this
morning so like things are moving on
that front but you guys get it Ben's
overriding point the same people who
have no problem with people screaming
calls for genocide and River to the Sea
and all of that stuff they will now
deeply try to hang it up on Elon Musk
that he is an anti-semite as a matter of
fact we should have shown you this clip
today uh but uh Ronda santis was on Jake
tapper's show yesterday and Jake Tapper
out of nowhere with no other previous
context tried to get Ron Des santis to
say that Elon Musk was an anti-semite
and Des santis just did a master class
like I'm not playing those games with
you uh type of answer uh this is a good
time for me to mention that we have
opened a new account on X to promote
this show so I'm separating sort of my
personal thoughts from the show
promotion uh so if you are on the
Twitter and if you're not God bless you
but if you are uh you can follow our
show account at Ruben report show on the
Twitter uh so what is the other big
thing that happened over the last couple
days that is deeply connected to all of
this woke Insanity that's deeply
connected to the bad guys being called
the good guys and the good guys being
called the bad guys well there is a new
president in Argentina uh here's a tweet
from Colin rug of trending politics meet
Argentina's new president Javier Malay
when he was growing up kids called him
the madman because of his energetic
outbursts at the age of 18 Malay who was
a soccer player gave up the sport to
pursue a career in economics Malay
started getting famous for debates on
live television where he would hurl
insults at his Rivals along with his
madman energy after a 2018 incident
where Malay called a journalist a donkey
a court a local court ordered a
psychological exam after he refused to
apologize for gender violence Malay
hates wokeism hates socialism hates the
media hates excessive government
spending hates the political Elite and
loves his country and now if you have
not seen Javier Malay here is a bit of a
compilation and enjoy
[Music]
min
I'll have what he's having yeah you can
see why something exciting is going to
be happening down in Argentina and now
the the question is will he be able to
do those things will he be able to cut
those agencies what will the globalists
in the world economic forum and
everything else every other like
globalist apparatus do to take out
Argentina right cuz they he's the Trump
of Argentina clearly what is with these
Boris Johnson has a two these people
like if you have crazy hair you
basically get good politics that has
somehow become a thing uh anyway he is
pissing off all of the right people
because he is he is you know they're
trying to frame him as like he's far
right the implication being he's somehow
racist even though there's no notion
that he's racist he just wants enough of
the government spending he hates the
wers and the Socialists but he is
pissing off all of the right people this
is three days ago so it's two days
before he got elected look what he had
the balls to do in
Argentina do we have it I think we have
it nope let's go back him yeah there he
is waving the Israeli flag and he just
won by a landslide so yeah he is going
to piss off all the right people just a
little more context on his election
actually from the guardian uh with more
than 99% of the votes counted the MC
Jagger impersonating TV celebrity term
politician who's often compared to
Donald Trump has secured 56% of the vote
compared with 44% for his rival the
center left Finance Minister Sergio Masa
and check out some of the celebrations
in Argentina people are happy you know
they have had a massive uh economic
meltdown in their country for the last
at least two decades and maybe you know
virtually everyone there works for the
government it got too big it wrecked
everything does that sound familiar but
maybe things are about to turn
around
vamos the man the myth the
[Applause]
legend have we got a Bitcoin president
with a
beautiful orange Bitcoin Sunset all
right so maybe some good things are
happening it's not often on this show
that we talk about Argentina but you
never know where like the The Comeback
is going to start from and and there
there is a beautiful beautiful moment
I'm going to show you one more of
harvier Malia in just a second but
before we do that everything that I have
talked about today is the stuff that you
know right oism socialism the gender
stuff
Alles into it
today um all of it has wrecked and
ransacked so much of what is good about
the West right we have people teaching
our kids not only that their genders
don't their genitals don't match their
gender but the very country they live in
is evil we have watched so many things
just absolutely collapsed and and we
need only look at a mirror it's on all
of us for what has happened here but we
haven't completely given it up yet so
now I would like to show you a warning
this is from George Orwell of course the
author of
1984 uh with his uh well they say this
is sort of uh his final warning to the
world and tell me uh does this seem
chilling yay or nay but he left one
final
warning you want claimed that you have
an ability to face unpleasant facts is
that what you've demonstrated in 1984 by
drawing an accurate portrait of the
future something like 1984 could
actually happen this is the direction
the world is going in at the present
[Music]
time in our world there will be no
emotions except fear rage Triumph and
self-abasement the sex Instinct will be
eradicated ated we shall abolish the
orgasm there will be no loyalty except
loyalty to the
party but always there will be the
intoxication of
power always at every moment there will
be the thrill of victory the sensation
of trampling on an enemy who
helpless if you want a picture of the
future imagine a boot
stamping on a human face
forever the moral to be drawn from this
dangerous nightmare situation is a
simple
one don't let it
happen it depends on
you way he looked into the camera there
you know like when I talk to you guys
and I'm like it's up to you it's the
same thing
no one will come and save you we're
going to occasionally get some
politicians that'll do some good right
but even they only appear because of us
and he is right George Orwell that's got
to be probably 50 years ago that video
something like that and he is right the
warning that he wrote in 1984 which was
well before that is that the West is
heading in this direction where it will
just be the boot on all of us but there
is good news they're also kind of stupid
the wers for all of their plan and the
Socialists for everything they've
wrecked they're not the brightest people
and and the human Spirit does win over
time so what I call on you to do today
is summon your in your inner Javier
Malia fight back call it out find your
inner cardi B get your bucket and
whatever she had on the side of the
bucket it was a whole thing and fix this
country and here's one more with
Javier
fore
foree
for
for those of you listening on the audio
podcast who didn't get the translation
there he Loosely said I don't like
leftists and you shouldn't either that
would be the rough translation of that
whole thing I think you get the point
guys there are people waking up there
are people voting the right way there
are more of us than there are of them we
just have to be brave enough to call a
spade a spade and then perhaps we can
fix this thing that is our MonDay
program for you uh if you want to join
us for the postgame show right now it's
Ruben report. locals . live at 1M on
people of the internet oh and my
interview with Stella Assange that is
Julian assange's wife we did that in
London at the ark conference which was
really I think it was about a mile and a
half if I'm not mistaken from where
Julian Assange is being held right now
in prison uh it was it was really
something else like powerful interview
uh you can check that out across
platforms and just another reminder if
you are on X Twitter follow the show
account at Ruben report show do we have
a meme Monday for the good people
I think we might have a mean Monday for
you yes this was my mean Monday and as
you can see uh people seem to only care
about dead people in the Middle East
when it has something to do with the
Jews and we better trust the Hamas
numbers uh but when you know 400 are
killed 400,000 are killed in the Iraq
war no protest Congo War about 900,000
you know a little little bit less you
get the point uh we leave you with oh
it's the birthday today of Joe how old
is he he's 81 is it 81 yeah Joe Biden is
81 today and here he is over the weekend
doing something strange with a
six-year-old child goodbye you thank you
and I love your ears I love them they're
really cool what's your name Catherine
Catherine what a beautiful name that's
my mommy's name well nice to see how old
are you
six
[Music]